good evening and welcome to fox news
primetime i'm trey gowdy
you know i wanted to start with
something hopeful and something
happy this evening and then ironically
enough
a woman named joy forced me to go in
another direction
joy reid that is from msnbc
and what was supposed to be a segment
about the minimum wage she could not
resist taking a shot at united states
senator tim
scott this is what she said
got to love the uh tim scott standing
there to provide the patina of diversity
over that uh
round of words that basket full of words
a patina of diversity to save you the
trouble of looking that word up
a patina is a superficial covering it's
her way
of calling senator scott a prop or a
token
but she's done that too in the past
while your appointment is seen by some
as a measure of progress
others have called you a mere token
elevated only to show that the gop has
gotten the diversity memo it missed this
past election
but i do hope that as a senator you'll
prove those who call you a
token wrong
for a party and a media that claim to
love civility and public discourse and
rooting out the hot political
rhetoric and finding some unity she has
a
really weird way of showing it like
ignoring policy debates and engaging in
personal attacks
if joy reid knew anything about tim
scott
she would understand full well why he
would be participating in a press
conference
on the minimum wage if she knew anything
about tim scott she would understand why
he is frequently
front and center in major policy debates
in washington tim scott was one of three
u.s
senators chosen to work on the tax
reform legislation
because he made himself an expert on the
issue
not because he's black he was a business
owner
he started a business he had to make
payroll
he had to access credit tim scott was at
the forefront on tax reform
because he's on the senate finance
committee because he was on the house
ways and means committee
because he dedicated himself to becoming
an expert
and yet at a press conference about tax
reform yet another
woke liberal referred to him as a prop
i cannot tell you the number of times
tim scott
excused himself from the dinner table in
washington
to take a call from a colleague while
the senate was negotiating and drafting
tax legislation they were not calling
tim scott because he is black
they were calling him because he is an
expert
in tax legislation he was at the
forefront of police reform legislation
because he knows what it's like to be
stopped while driving
stop while someone else is driving and
he was even stopped from entering the
united states capital
he also knows the power of a justice
system that is respected
and worthy of respect he knows the
anguish of officer-involved shootings
and he knows the pain and the grief
spouses of police officers feel
because he is the first one to call the
surviving spouse
of a dead police officer he was at the
forefront
of this debate because he's lived this
debate in a way that very few other
united states senators
ever have or ever will you know kamala
harris and cory booker
were part of that national debate as
well but neither one of them was called
a token
by liberal senator dick durbin but tim
scott was
tim scott is at the forefront of issues
in washington
because he has earned the right to be
there
through hard work through learning the
issues through experiencing the issues
and through the respect earning the
respect of his peers
on both sides of the aisle you know
julie reed is welcome to have whatever
political belief she wants i don't think
she's ever run for office before and my
guess is
she wouldn't win if she did that's
policy
but when she calls a united states
senator who's a subject matter expert
a prop a token or a superficial covering
that's personal and that's wrong
and she should be held to account now
i'm having to say this now because when
tim scott joins us in just a moment
he won't say any of this
he's humble he's driven by policy and
not personal attacks
he doesn't make personal attacks he
rarely responds to those
made against him by others he is driven
by
faith which is the cornerstone of his
life
you know not the faith where god tells
you to do the easy things
the kind of faith will you actually
forgive people when it's hard
in short tim scott is too good of a
person to respond to the likes of joy
reid
but i am not tim scott is a united
states senator
who worked his tail off to be part of
nearly every significant policy
conversation
this country has he can stand wherever
the hell he wants to stand
and any group he wants to stand with
because he's earned
the right to be there the fact that you
see a black man as a prop joy read
says a lot more about you than it does
about tim scott
i see a united states senator
and if you really were interested in
unity or fair treatment or respect and
civil discourse
that's what you would see too
and now the senator from the great state
of south carolina
tim scott thank you for joining us
senator
jay what's up buddy how are you good i
had to get a little something off my
chest
but uh thank you for joining us i
actually don't want to talk to you about
any of that i want to talk to you about
what's in the
coveted relief bill that the senate just
passed and what should we be scared of
well thank you straight let me just say
this on what you just said woke
supremacy
is as bad as white supremacy we need to
take that seriously
and to all those folks who oppose good
common sense
matthew 5 44 is still available to be
read
in red but to the covid relief package
let me just say this
it is not a coveted relief package it's
more of a progressives
payment plan because it pays everybody
it pays cities
it pays states it pays prisoners think
about this trade
california that is predicted to have a
19
billion dollar surplus gets 40
billion dollars out of the fund of 350
billion dollars
set aside for states who need help if
you don't need help
you shouldn't get it and why is the
taxpayer
or why are all taxpayers funding and
subsidizing
blue states that have surpluses
one percent of this bill trade one
percent
goes to vaccines less than 10 percent
goes to covid relief in other words as
bernie sanders said it
this is the most progressive piece of
legislation
to pass the senate since he's been a
senator
that says a lot when you make bernie
sanders blush
over progressive policies
well i hate to be cynical and i hate to
be slow but if i hear you right what
you're saying is the coveted relief bill
doesn't have all that much to do with
covet it's kind of a christmas
list for the progressives absolutely
trey if you think about the fact that
unemployment is going to be extended
through september
even though just this week we added 379
000 jobs and our unemployment rate went
down
if you think about the fact that they're
literally going to cut a check
to new parts of the american economy
because they can it's hard to spend two
trillion dollars and oh by the way this
is the only relief bill that was
purely partisan not a single republican
in the senate
voted for it the five previous relief
bills
under senate republican majority 90 plus
senators
voted for all of them five ninety
one zero for a senate that is 50 50
it sure doesn't feel like it that's bad
for the american taxpayer
you know senator you're right it's 50 50
and that hardly seems the time to be
pursuing this transformative
generational change but it seems like
that
is what the democrats are heck ben on
trying to do
even in an evenly divided senate we got
about
we got about a minute what else is
coming up that the american people
should be fearful of from this
50 senators over playing their hand
you should you should look for another
round of the minimum wage
and also look for the greatest
transformation of voting we've ever seen
in this country
what we saw in 2020 all the challenges
that we saw
should be taken care of but what the
democrats want to do is codifying law
allowing a 16 year old vote not an 18
but a 16 year old
they're looking for ways to transform
the way that we vote in this nation
we should stand strong for things like
voter id
eliminating or reducing the amount of
mail-in ballots
we should find ways to focus on states
responsibilities for voting
not nationalizing voting and then
there's something called the equality
act the only thing that it's not
is equal it's not fair it discriminates
against women
this that's what they're going to do for
the next several weeks we have to block
and tackle like we've never done before
well you're an old college football
player of course i think you were on the
other side of the ball
but uh i got all the confidence in the
world and it's great to see you thank
you for joining us i'll see you soon
thank you trey